[Musique]
un peu de rock de pop de chansons
françaises les superets c'est un mélange
de divers styles musicaux Serina n'aime
pas les étiquettes d'ailleurs se produa
dark réputé pour son stage de danse ça
ne les perturbe pas
vraiment sachant qu'un fois on a fait un
concert dans un festival de montolfierre
j'ai envie de dire que plus rien nous
est frais donc donc je veux dire la
danse c'est que ça c'est commun du coup
à côté des mongoles
fi par que moi j'ai j'ai vraiment hâte
de voir la foule en juste au corps faire
des rubans et du ballon pendant que on
fait notre rock and roll ça serait
vraiment bien
[Musique]
rigolo aucune extravagance de ce genre
côté public mais il est conquis il
mérite le coup de voir ouais franchement
c'est des jeunes très dynamiques c'est
vraiment très bien c'était très
dynamique très très très bien des jeunes
qui qui ont l'air d'en vouloir
qui m'écoute Bruno regarde tes
arrières visiblement le tour de chauffe
des suérettes n'a pas impressionné
Benabar son deè passage à Dark après
2004 coïcide avec ses 20 ans de carrière
soutenu par des fans toujours très
enthousiastes habituellement je vois la
télévision mais sur scène c'est une
autre dimension super concert voilà les
classiques les Ch les plus récentes
qu'on a 15 ans ou 60 ans ou même 80
c'est génial donc voilà faut continuer
alors merci beaucoup Bruno
benar encore C aut soiré de concert
avant que la partie musicale de la 40e
édition de Dark ne tire sa
révérence